[Music]
hey guys it's Jonah here so a lot of you
must be wondering what goes behind the
life of a fitness youtuber well a lot
has changed since I started four years
ago so let me just take you through my
typical day okay I like to start my
morning strong that means before I get
on with any work I'll aim to hit the gym
first thing in the morning on a busy day
I'll introduce older body circuit
training mixed in with running to build
strength burn fat and also to boost my
energy levels this would typically take
me about 45 minutes long and I like to
keep my workout sessions efficient and
effective it's really important that I
feel my body right after my workout
session hi
I'm going to have one tropical green
juice alright
I'm also gonna use the boost payment
voucher as someone who tends to leave
her wallet and keys everywhere using
this app is really convenient it's just
a click away to purchase the voucher
when I'm in a rush the easiest way is to
just grab a juice or smoothie which as
you know contains natural sugars
electrolytes and amino acids to help my
muscles recover faster and to be
stronger so I'm just heading back right
now I'm going to freshen up and my team
will be heading over and we will be
filming a couple of recipe videos
[Music]
hey wait yeah okay so you guys are
arriving in about half an hour time okay
right no problem I'll transfer some
money across and oh yeah I think just
get one extra cabbage and also two
cucumbers see you guys bye sparing some
money so my team is here right now we're
just setting up my goddess Monday
morning everybody's like hi I'm coffee
but anyway we're favoring to recipe
videos
one Christmas recipe and it was so
another what are we doing you waiting
what are you doing
sauerkraut and she's just washing the
cabbage right now look at that I'm sure
a lot of you know that I used to do
everything on my own and it can get
really stressful
I'm not blessed with this amazing team
they help me out with all my video
productions we are still a very small
team but hey their support is huge I
usually can't remember everything I'm
going to say when I film a video so what
I do is I'll put it down in point forms
and then I'll refer to it as and when
are we rolling let's do it
hey it's the festive season I love this
time of the year
everything looks extra pretty so are you
planning a family dinner with your loved
ones all right we got this we got this
all right let's do this
ready go I'm always right in the middle
of things when I'm creating all these
videos for you from conceptualizing to
directing filming the shoots and sitting
down with my editors overlooking all the
finer detail
I like to plan ahead to ensure that you
all get at least two videos every week
on time hey I'm a perfectionist
I'm at a photo shoot right now with
Dermalogica Malaysia as part of their
fight for healthy skin campaign which
will also be featured in female magazine
so I actually made some coconut
macaroons bliss balls and yeah this
really helps to give me some energy to
keep going
especially on a busy day and it's really
easy to be eaten perfect when you're on
the go so now we're just going to head
into the studio and get a couple of
pictures come on I have extremely
sensitive skin guys one moment it's fine
another moment it breaks out like crazy
so I do understand the struggle just for
one picture it usually takes more than
three hours behind the scenes now that's
a wrap it's been a long day but I'm not
done just yet
so I'm still over shoot and I've packed
a really simple lunch to go my favourite
glass noodle salad and guys remember
when you're eating just put your phones
away okay you're survived without it no
distractions
so I used to work and do everything from
home but now this is where I work from
since starting her Network
I have daily meetings with other
Creators to bounce ideas off each other
I want to continue to create a
meaningful and valuable content for all
of you and I'm only able to do that
better when I have other people to share
my vision with and yes your feedback and
suggestions matter I'm just about to
meet a Sandra for dinner some of you
might have seen her on my YouTube
channel where she shares practical and
really useful tips on how to be happy
always let's go find Andrea it's been a
really long day so it's nice to be able
to just hang out with someone who gets
you and just chat and chat away as you
can see I don't always cook all my meals
hey it's about balance I do enjoy eating
out with my family and friends
I haven't played in almost ten years and
I only started picking it up again three
months ago these days I try to play
every night before I go to bed just to
help me wind down do something in the
evening that helps you wind down and
before you sleep just ask yourself what
has been the highlight of my day